when you bring a guy like Joe Concha in
on a Friday you gotta come up with at
least two topics and we think we came up
with one CNN has spent most of this past
week breathlessly reporting every detail
about a white truck they believe
President Trump sent to keep the media
from watching him golf at merrill ago
the president also got back on the golf
course but not that we can prove it
because a giant white box truck blocks
reporters what's up with the white truck
blocking his golf swing this is a White
House that seems particularly sensitive
for whatever reason about images of
President Trump on a golf course this
truck showed up out of nowhere and we
don't know where it came from now back
to that mysterious truck [ __ ] in the
president's call swing from the cameras
one of the advantages of have your own
golf courses you could also get a guy to
get in a truck to block that golf course
from the road what was the obsession
there I mean what how could they focus
like not only are his tweets programmed
the entire network but so are his non
actions we ever think about what was in
the box truck could that's in the ice
cream that brings two scoops of ice
cream remember that was a sign end
report that was job has two instead of
one or maybe how many diet cokes he's
having it's delivering Diet Coke so
maybe that should be the investigation
look CNN is not the network that it once
was under the Aaron Browns and a Bernard
Shaw's what's a big story this year
Brian that almost no one's talking about
the Isis Caliphate being decimated in
Iraq and Syria
they've lost 98 percent of their
territory they once had 45,000 fighters
two years ago they have less than 1,000
now if there was ever a story that was
in CNN's wheelhouse given what they've
done in the past in terms of their
Middle East reporting this is it the
ISIS story and I don't see too much
coverage on that and I see crap and this
is crap these cuts of focus right now
from a once-proud network that shouldn't
be covering this sort of stuff it's
ridiculous Joe they do have an agenda
they are obsessed with destroying him
it's coming from the upper echelons of
CNN no matter who owns them and they've
gotten some stories wrong because of
that anthe scaramouche e41 links to the
Russian government and they had to
apologize for that apologize and they
fired three reporters that were on that
that they basically just had hired one
actually won a Pulitzer gone and then of
course a couple of weeks ago that
WikiLeaks story that they had they said
that Donald
jr. in the Trump campaign had
information 10 days before everybody
else it turned out it was already in the
public domain and that's because they
don't relied on unnamed sources that
also dupe CBS and NBC they should reveal
who that source was because that source
was purposely putting out false
information whoever that may have been a
political operative or even a lawmaker
and that Washington Post did something
right there Brian they asked for the
document actual evidence to see if
Donald Trump jr. got that or not it took
two minutes for them to get it
CNN went to air with it so I look I
don't want to stomp on CNN and say like
this is a bad Network and everybody is
bad there I think Jake Tapper does some
good stuff but they have good reporters
great producer Allison Cammarata is my
my female idol we just saw Dave Briggs
right on there as well who's Fox and
Friends they have some good people there
but when they keep doing stories like
this it destroys the credibility of a
very once proud Network get back to the
guys you used to be focus on News and
stop focusing so much on taking down a
president last thing prediction in 2018
will there be less anti Trump and more
balanced on the to knock him down when
he they think he's wrong but but also
note the stock market the economy the
passage of the tax reform see more of a
balance the toothpaste is already out of
the tube you know they say about putting
toothpaste a tube or you can't unring a
bell
we've already down that path CNN's made
a business decision to go negative on
Donald Trump the problem is they lost
audience in primetime from the previous
year think about 2017 too chaotic great
near for new year for news in terms of
consumers bringing it in and they
actually lost audience that's very hard
to do
Joe concha it's very nice of you to come
in on this beautiful Friday
it's gorgeous out as I yeah it really go
swimmin yeah you definitely should wear
a coat okay
don't lick a pole